you're sitting there and it's incredibly
frustrating it's maddening you've been
sitting there for hours filling in those
little tiny circles with your number-two
pencil this is a standardized test you
look up half a race chalkboard you can
see that perfectly written cursive
alphabet the pulldown maps you can hear
tick tick tick tick ticking on the wall
that industrial clock but most
importantly you can feel that oppressive
florescent light that death-ray over
your head and you can't take it anymore
but you don't have to because miss
darling says okay boys and girls you're
done so you jump up I mean there is
nothing left of you but a vapor trail
you move so quickly you slam that little
molded plastic chair and you sprint down
the hallway you go past the lice all
smell in the Bo smell and the copies and
you push the door and finally you're
outside ah you can feel the wind on your
face and the Sun on your skin most
importantly the big blue sky that is a
revelation of space and making
revelations of space is what I do I'm a
designer and a creative director that's
what I do for a living and I do it for
all sorts of people in all kinds of
different ways and it might seem
complicated but it's not over the next
couple of minutes I'm going to give you
three ways that I think you can move
through your world so the you too can
make revelations of space or at least
reveal them step 1
therapy I know I know I know I know
blah blah blah New Yorker bubble about
therapy but seriously therapy you have
to know why you're doing these things
right so when I got the job of designing
hamilton i sat with my mom miranda
writer tommy kale director and I said
why are we telling this two hundred and
forty six year old story what is it
about the story that you want to say and
what do you want people to feel like
when they experience the show it's
important when we get that we move into
step two that's the design phase and
I'll give you some little tricks about
that but the design phase
is important because we get to make
these cool toys right I reach into Lin's
brain he reaches into mind this
monologue becomes a dialogue and I make
these cool toys and I say does this
world look like the world that you think
could be a place where we can house your
show if the answer is yes and when the
answer is yes we move into what I think
is the most terrifying part which is the
execution phase and the execution phase
when we get to build this thing and when
this conversation goes from a few people
to a few hundred people now translating
this idea we put it in this this
beautiful little thing we put it in the
Honey I Shrunk the Kids super sizer
machine and blow it up full-scale and we
never know if we did it right until we
show up on stage and go does it okay is
it okay here's the thing you don't have
to be Lin you don't have to have a book
that you want to turn into a show in
order to do this in your real life
you're already starring in a show by the
way it's called your life
congratulations
but seriously Shakespeare said it all
the world's a stage he nailed that part
what he screwed up royally was that part
where he said and we are merely players
it's ridiculous we're not merely players
we are the costume designers and the
lighting designers and the makeup
artists in our own world and I want to
get you to think about being the set
designer in your world because I think
you can leave here if you do these three
steps and a couple of little tricks as I
said I'm gonna tell you and you can
begin to change the world the way you
want to you want to do it okay
everybody write a show no it's good okay
step one therapy right how are you
feeling how are you that so the
therapist says how are you feeling today
it's important to remember that because
when we designed the world for you the
therapy is important it tells you that
emotion is going to become light and
color and a good example of that light
and color is a show I design called the
urban Hanson the urban Hanson exists oh
my god
here it is it exists in a world of
almost all light in color so I chose a
color inky black darkness inky black
darkness is a color the way that sadness
is an emotion and this show transforms
people but not
for it wrecks people so I bet you're
wondering how expensive could the set
possibly be to transform you if you sit
for two hours and 20 minutes in inky
black darkness
the answer is cheap inky black darkness
turn the lights on at the right time
seriously think about leaving miss
darlings class inky black darkness gives
way at the right moment we fly away that
wall and reveal a beautiful blue sky it
blows people away and it transports them
it makes them feel hopeful and we know
this because color is emotion and when
you paint with color you're painting
with feelings so think about that
emotion the one that I had you file away
in your mental rolodex what color is it
where in your wardrobe does it exist and
where in your home does it exist when we
design the show for you
we're gonna use that color to tell you
how you feel in certain times but also
you know this exists because you put the
hero and why you put the lead character
in red
you put the villain and all black it's
typecast and you know that so think
about it but there's also something else
that happens in the world that helps us
move through the world in a safe way
they're called architectural standards
they make us not fall down and go boom
doorknobs are all at the same high light
switches are all at the same height
toilet bowls are always thank God at the
same height because no one ever misses
the toilet ball but seriously what would
happen if we started to tweak those
architectural standards to get what we
wanted it reminds me of the stairs I
made for pee-wee Herman pee-wee Herman
is a child and his entire world is
created so that we perceive pee-wee as a
child the architecture and the furniture
and everything come to life but nothing
more important than those stairs those
stairs are 12 inches high so when
pee-wee clumps up and down those stairs
he interact with them like a kid you
can't fake that kind of interaction and
that's the exact opposite of what we ask
people and opera to do an opera we
shrink those stairs so that our main
characters can glide up and down
effortlessly without ever breaking their
voice you could never put an opera
singer in pee-wee's Playhouse har they
wouldn't be able to do their job right
but you
put peewee in an opera set couldn't
climb up and down those stairs there'd
be no peewee he'd be like James Bond
slinking elegantly up and down the
stairs
it wouldn't work so now think of your
sad your home but you exist in every
single day you're anything like me the
trashcan is just too small for the
amount of takeout that you buy every
night right and I find myself jamming
like I'm kneading dough in a pizza place
I'm jamming it in because I don't
understand
or maybe the light switch in your foyer
is just stash behind too many
precariously placed coats and so you
don't even go for it therefore day after
day you wind up walking in and out of a
chasm of darkness it's true but what
would happen if the space revealed
something about yourself that you didn't
even know Kanye never told me
specifically that he wanted to be God
but when we started working together but
when we started working together we were
sending images back and forth and he
sent me a picture of the aurora borealis
with lightning strikes through it and he
sent me pictures from a mountaintop
looking down to the filled smoke-filled
Canyon or smoke underneath the surface
of a water like epic stuff so the first
two said I design for him was a huge
light box of the name of his record
label he would stand there triumphantly
in front of it it would flash lights
like a lightning bolt and it was epic
but like starter-kit epic we moved on to
a large swath of sky with a tear down
the middle and through the tear you
could see deep parts of the cosmos
getting closer we evolved to standing on
top of obelisk standing on top of
mountainside standing on top of boxes
you know he was evolving as an artist
through space and it was my job to try
and keep up when we did Coachella there
he was standing in front of an 80 foot
wide by 40 foot tall ancient artifact
literally handed down from God to man he
was evolving and we were all witness to
it and in his last show which I didn't
design but I witnessed he had self
actualized he was literally standing on
a floating Plexiglas deck over his
adoring fans who had no choice but to
praise Jesus up above
he identified himself you can't become
Jesus in your living room the space told
him who he was about himself and then he
delivered that to us
when I was 20 years old I was driving
through her parking lot and I saw a
puddle I thought I'm gonna veer to the
left nah I'm going through it and I hit
the puddle and like all the water
underneath my car and instantly I have
an aha moment light bulb goes off
everything in the world needs to be
designed I mean I'm sure what I was
thinking is actually the drainage needs
to be designed in this parking lot but
then I quickly was like everything in
the world needs to be designed and it's
true because left to its own devices
mother nature is not gonna carve an
interesting or necessarily helpful path
for you I've spent my career reaching
into people's minds and creating worlds
out here that we can all interact with
and yeah you might not get to do this
with fancy collaborators but I think if
you leave here
those three easy steps therapy who do I
want to be why do I do the things I do
design create a plan and try and follow
through with it what can I do execute it
I think if you add that with a little
color Theory some cool design choices in
a general disrespect for architectural
standards you can go out and create the
world that you want to live in and I I'm
going to go home and buy new trash can
[Music]